hello and welcome to this video playing
am Ziggler with that Magnus sagaris oh
my god and no idea who that is so what
is going on here yet super solid Italian
game where I keep getting in trouble and
maybe I just never feel that this this
can't be anything and then I had
problems i recently got a book actually
about this opening mostly like for the
white side but i felt like maybe i can
benefit from looking at a little bit but
I so don't understand it I still have no
idea what's going on
the main problems actually that i always
think nothing is going on and then I'm
good all of a sudden always things like
I mean how can this be anything I mean
black looks more actors got more space
why isn't like fine and then I have
problems all of a sudden so and what am
I doing here lie down 85 of course is an
annoying piece this is clear well should
be six is going cleantech three and then
there's night h6 coming so I'm not quite
sure what to do here
who
I see no constructive plan 1987 this is
what I was coming up this one this is
what I'm coming up now with that's
probably a weird sentence anyway I'm
trying to say if that's my idea
a 360 can actually take on age 60 not
good
well maybe I can still play that so we
are then eat night h6 Queen g4 I can
take with the night yeah I can just take
h 6 m of course Knight takes Knight eggs
can even play Queen age for maybe oh wow
and if I play this pretty awful ace is
opening what is the problem me I don't
get it or does she have something
stronger that's possible was a channel D
for so is there something spectacular or
queen h4
queen age for could be could be more
yeah that's probably what is what is
trying to figure out no ok so light
takes clean edge for strong I have to do
this as awful as it looks like so let's
go where five gain some space at least
ok I mean f4 is a threat and I have some
reasonable space at least
I don't think this is so easy for y to
play is certainly better but playing is
not that easy I feel okay so who's and
form we have four so simply geez form I
wonder ever should go be five young
let's do it prevent him from playing b5
it looks loose though
okay so I was thinking I could try to
attack here I probably not 92 is coming
up this was my original idea what yeah
is coming down
[Music]
time warning to see why I cannot take it
okay once you put it on you for this is
clear but yeah threatening made yeah
still I mean okay not so easy here to
play for him maybe I can night to III
would be fantastic check check
[Music]
don't have to play okay yeah come on
that it was I mean I was really getting
back into this and I'm blundering it
away one reason is terrible yeah yeah I
mean I'm just winning me of course by
taking just by taking because their book
takes look he sees his tangle lucky with
the bishop stupid I love making making
use of my chances not at all yeah I mean
at first it was that was completely
outplayed of course and then he was
letting me back into the game the system
look good at all x6 was also very bad
and yeah he I mean he took on age 6
which is good of course I was thinking
this might work as well I couldn't
calculated but f6 seems to hold him what
he did is good I mean it's just clearly
better in this position but then I was
getting back into this like tremendously
and he mostly blunder g4 in one more and
then this is a just King Jesus just
taking wind stirs this is this is
terrible terrible yeah just look at the
false move okay I mean this looks nice
see I put put the knife down and it also
probably yes should because when I was
completely losing track now
yeah this is just stupid stupid to know
and now is losing track yet completely
yeah I know this opening is is really
really weird I die I don't understand
understand the opening simply don't
understand that I mean this position I
simply see no idea I mean night comes to
have 5am are already doing something
wrong I understand that the computer
self its equal but I I don't quite
understand this at all I mean black is
fully centralized I've got every piece
in the center white have little space
just test this idea okay and they don't
have anything good I don't know I don't
get it I don't get this position funny
things the engine is actually playing
playing what I did so I found something
quite quite decent but they have to play
h 898 very strange anyway thanks for
watching